foreign
[Music]
edition of spectator TV the local
election results are partly in so we're
going to take this moment to look at
what we can tell from the results so far
to do this I'm joined by Fraser Nelson
and James Johnson the pollster so to
begin
um James we're at that point where
there's still several results more to
come in in fact quite a lot though I
imagine once the king's coronation gets
underway they'll be getting a little bit
less attention on on this television
than they are now but what do you think
the main takeaways are so far
well I think this is clearly a good
night for labor there's no doubt about
that it clearly puts labor in the
advantage position for the next general
election
um it's also good for the live Dems
clearly they're able to make the Headway
in those blue wall seats that the
conservatives are defending uh in the
South
um having said all that when we look at
the national equivalent vote Yes the
conservatives are down
um uh in terms of their behind labor
um but labor are not sort of getting a
double digits huge lead at least with
the professor Michael Thrasher
projection um he's saying that labor
will be on between uh 38 to 40 and that
the conservatives will be on between 28
to 30 so what that means is is that if
that was replicated in a general
election there would be a hung
Parliament with labor as the largest
party so what we're not seeing here is a
90s Blair style Wipeout for labor
um and nor are we seeing a particularly
good result for the conservatives I
think it confirms what we knew already
in some ways there is a path for the
conservatives at the next election but
it's a very narrow one once you throw in
Scotland into the mix once you've thrown
squeezing your lip Dems into the mix it
may well be harder still but I think it
does show that the next selection does
remain open and perhaps some of those
labor claims that uh this shows they're
on they're set for government were a
little a little premature this morning
yes phrase it feels though leave is
trying to set the narrative which is a
brilliant result for them and as James
said it's clearly a good result if you
have Kirsten saying we're on course for
a majority government echoed by his
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves
um do you think do you think people from
labor will be uh happy with the result
John Curtis the polling professor said
that really labor needed a 10-point lead
to show their own apartment
well when you look at laborers
objectives and the locals and they
wanted Swindon they got Swindon they've
got Plymouth they've got stuck on Trent
they've got Medway the Tories have lost
lots of councils here so that
objectively is a success for the labor
party
um now I got an email from them as
something like five to six this morning
um saying that that we are conferenced
we're going to be eight points ahead and
if we're eight points ahead that means
we're going to be getting a majority at
the next general election now as um I'm
not quite sure why they were confidence
because at the time there were just a
few
um doesn't really cancels return the
results and right now it looks like
there might be between 6 and 10 points
ahead
um but you know we'll see we'll see I
mean by the time you know this time
tomorrow we should know that for sure
but even then we know that local
election results are a broad indicator
but not a very reliable indicator of a
general election results we also can see
the national opinion portrait and when
Russia first took over he was 30 points
behind a labor party that Gap is now
narrowed between 30 to 15 points now if
that Gap can get beneath 10 points by
the time of the new year then all of a
sudden you've got a competitive general
election now just think back to where
the Tories were in the trough of Liz
trust stays they would have given their
eye teeth for a competitive general
election it looks completely in the bag
for labor it looks less so now now I am
I'm useless at political predictions I
stopped I think 2016 was less time I am
I made one so I right now will talk in
percentages and say that I would give
sunac a one in three chance of winning
the next election when he first became
leader I would have given him a one in
seven chance and today's results sort of
underline that for me because
um the wave at the the boundary changes
work labor do need to be significantly
ahead and so victories can actually be
behind labor and voting share of general
election still emerge below just single
party so they could still end up as
prime minister so we're not in that
smashing territory yet but I think it's
a bit mean to say therefore labor has
failed labor has scored a string of
local government successes and I think
there is testimony to the recovery
they've made from the mess that labor
was in in the Corbin era and starmer's
work personally reaching out the
corbinistas putting the moderates back
in charge and you can even see I was
fascinated to see analysis showing that
brexit voting constituencies were
swinging harder to labor than the remain
ones so a sign perhaps of Labor getting
his old voters back
James what do you say to that
Brazil the Tories are also losing
support in quite a few of these remain
air voting areas
um particularly you know in some of
these uh Southern strongholds
traditionally
yeah well if you look at the polling
over the last year or so and you look at
the voters that have left the
conservatives
um they tend to be lead voters and they
tend to be more working class they tend
to be slightly older and they tend to
have voted for brexit in that 2016
referendum uh that is worrying for the
conservatives because obviously those
those voters are concentrated in those
places that gave them the majority last
time around in the north uh and the
Midlands and of course there are plenty
of those voters in the South too
um and actually you can see those uh
those voters having an impact in the
South even in those more what we would
call blue wall or middle class liberal
areas actually they often have a large
contingent of Voters that look like that
too even if they're not in the majority
so I think that's absolutely right look
I think I think the question here is is
for the next election is
is the weakness in the conservative
position structural
um are they going to lose to the lib
Dems almost regardless because the brand
is that damaged in the South are they
going to see Labor uh significantly
increase their position in Scotland uh
and in Wales
um and fundamentally
um can they is there anyone more for
them to squeeze I think that's one
interpretation and then obviously we are
headed even with this relatively good
but not amazing labor position headed
towards a labor government the flip side
is effectively what Fraser's saying
which is oh the scenario that Fraser's
saying which is that Labor uh continues
to lose their polling lead and there's
absolutely no doubt that uh if these
elections will run six months ago they
would have been one heck of a lot worse
for the conservatives than they were uh
than they were this week
um so Richie sunac has helped narrow
that Gap the question is whether he can
do it anymore or whether there's a
structural limit on that I lean towards
thinking that there is is more that he
can do only because when you put sunak
and stalma up against each other in the
polling in the focus groups things are a
lot tighter Suna can stoma weren't on
the ballot this week but they will be at
a general election and James just on
that point if you uh I suppose looking
at the 2019 election which clearly had
lots of factors that you're not going to
repeat the next time around
um but when we look at some of those
blue wall seats so for example when Alex
truck kept Shelton him lots of people
thought that was one notorious might
lose
um do you think one of the things that
helped the Tories in 2019 with these
voters specifically was Jeremy corbyn
the fact that lived um you know perhaps
Tori lived and vote to switch voters
didn't want Jeremy corbinary prime
minister in which case having kids style
make you not you might you might not be
infused by him but he's not frightened
by the prospect it is harder to hold
those areas potentially
yeah I I think that's I think that's
right and I think that uh that's one
thing that labor will be hoping will
mean that the live demo in those areas
is still relatively High
um and when you look at the kirst armor
versus Rishi sunak numbers amongst those
voters that kirst armor tends to have a
small lead
um but having said all that Richie sunac
does appeal to those voters more than
Boris Johnson all is trusted
um uh so there is a there is a chance
that you know the reverse happens he
Shores up a little bit of that but yeah
absolutely no doubt that would be what
conservatives will be thinking about now
if you're in an area like Isha and
Walton like Cheltenham like Stroud how
do you squeeze that the demo and make
sure that actually it's it's siding with
you rather than with rather than with
labor and uh at the moment based on
these results that's looking
increasingly difficult for the Tories to
do Fraser is clearly been a difficult uh
result for the tourists even if there is
a path I mean effectively I suppose it's
confirming the polls
um but do you think this is going to see
any change engine strategy from number
10 or do you think they want to say you
know we have a plan just don't focus on
these elections no I don't think
there'll be any change in strategy uh
Rishi snake wants to make a virtue of
consistency here and you can hear him on
there so when he was asked about the
results he was saying oh yes the message
I get from this is people want me to
focus on their priorities and their
priorities are every list is five plans
so um I think this five-point plan that
you did in January he's going to be
reinforcing now and he basically is
hoping for some small boats action there
was the court of appeal case last week
we don't know what it found but if it
found for the government then there
might be Jets taking off for Rwanda
um sooner rather than later in which
case he's hoping this will be a sort
from a stone moment he can stop the
small boats nobody thought he could and
then he'll be able to take inflation
which is still looking as if it's going
to safely beat his targets of being cut
in half by the end of the year so he is
still very much looking forward to these
promises he's made coming good and then
he wants to give another five plans he
wants to say in January next year Well I
achieved those five now I'm going to
achieve these slightly more
um imaginative harder to achieve five
and that will be his election pledge so
this is not somebody who will tear up
his plan and change it when he
encountered turbulence in the local
ancient results that's the sort of thing
that Boris Johnson might have done but
um it's not very cynic of course we need
to remember that Sonic himself was
campaigning quite a lot it's not a
strong suit this is a guy who lost a
campaign to Liz truss and couldn't even
win a vote amongst his own
um party members let alone the general
public so the great he's unusual here
because most people become Party leaders
or prime ministers after they've won a
general election who led the party
through a campaign sunak has had no real
proper campaign experience in fact the
locals have been pretty much for close
to she's going to get it and now I don't
think he was a disaster but nor did he
distinguish himself either and that's
what we have to remember we're in a
general election we're heading towards
one we're neither kirst armor nor Rishi
sunak is a particularly flamboyant and
effective campaigner in the way that
um but Tony Blair and the way that said
Boris Johnson were
um they're going to try to find each
other in a test of competence and I
think as far as concerned that
competence comes and sticking to a plan
once you've hashed one and just finally
James you touched on some of the
structural factors that could help labor
so part of the reason they're saying
with an eight point um you know swing
that they can still uh with a majority
is because of the situation in Scotland
I've spoken to some down-hearted Tory
MPS when I use all the s p collapse uh
effectively saying okay Starman could
not get any luckier as a leader with
some of these things coming up what do
you think is the best case scenario in
terms of what needs to go right for
Richie sunac to make that very narrow
path that you've talked about happen
so I think phrase is absolutely right um
it's going to be down to those five
promises this year um if he can get to
the end of this year inflation will
significantly down progress on small
boats progress on some of the other
issues uh then he will be able to turn
around and say look I've managed to do
these things and what we see in the
polling is that voters don't expect
those things to happen so if he can Buck
expectations then that may well shift
the view of him and allow him to assert
more of a lead over kirst armor um in
those best PM numbers which are
absolutely critical and you think that
would then feed through to voting
attention
um he then needs to do something even
more which is that in the you know he
then needs to set out of his Future
Vision you know what's his exciting
vision for the country I think one thing
that the con trap that the conservatives
must not fall into is to assume that
voters want stability
um they want uh um you know continuity
rather than change
um and that's something that Boris
Johnson very much grafted in 2019
um it's something that Theresa May
didn't grasp in 2017 and that was a
continuity campaign that about stability
so Richie's unit would also need to
deliver that exciting Vision that he can
say based on 2023 that he's able to
deliver so if those things take place
look you'd hope also that the SMP vote
would Shore up a little bit in Scotland
there's no doubt that that would help
the conservatives
um then then that path is there but I do
want to emphasize you know um I
sometimes get a bit of flack for saying
you know all the conservatives you know
might win the next general election it
is a might all I'm saying is is that
it's open and there's a there's a path
but there is a world in which when you
sit back and you look at these results
when you look back at the overall
overall picture SMP rise in Scott SMP
collapse in Scotland
labor ahead on voting and tension and on
who's best to handle the economy and of
course the new number tonight uh today
which is labor now having more being set
to have more councilors in England than
the conservatives overall you could look
at those and think these are the
historical markers that suggest we might
be heading towards a labor government
all I would say is that I do think
although it's Advantage labor things are
still ultimately up for grabs and as
Fraser says originally seen that will be
sitting tight and thinking there's a way
you can close the gap thank you James
thank you Fraser and thank you for
watching
[Music]
foreign